Sydney had two flights and her first
flight
they both gave them popcorn if popcorn
was a hazard why are they giving it on
planes Jesse James Decker and her sister
Sydney Ray bass sparked one seriously
heated parenting debate online when
those kinds of things happen you go to
the extreme and I went to the extreme no
really even Chrissy Teigen is weighing
in I love it it all started when Jesse
called out United Airlines on her insta
story over the weekend her sis who is
pregnant with her third child texted
Jesse while traveling solo with her
daughters two-year-old Blair and
five-year-old Brooklyn according to the
singer Blair accidentally spilled some
popcorn in the aisle that's when a
flight attendant allegedly approached
Sydney with a trash bag and a wet wipe
and told her the captain wanted her to
clean up every drop my poor sister is on
her hands and knees crying in the aisle
completely humiliated and exhausted with
her children while everyone else watched
way to go united did isn't that wild
Jesse later shared this selfie with her
niece writing grabbed my sis and the
popcorn Hazard yes that's what the
flight attendant told my sister that
popcorn in the aisle is a safety hazard
but Jesse wasn't the only one to speak
up Sydney's husband Anthony bass tweeted
about the alleged incident sharing this
pic of the popcorn on the floor and
writing in part are you kidding me the
airline replied to his tweet saying they
understand his concern and plan to
investigate what happened but the whole
thing sparked a debate online about
whose responsibility it was to clean up
the mess giving so much to your children
can be so amazing but it is obviously
draining Chrissy Teigen even entered the
chat tweeting oh man this is exactly
exactly the kind of tweet twitterers
love it's ridiculous all because of
Twitter comments on hinged from both
sides lots of passion being displayed 10
10 out of 10. I think Twitter is kind of
a snarky fun place and when one Twitter
user criticized Sydney suggesting that
she shouldn't have given her kids
popcorn in the first place Anthony shut
it down tweeting United provided the
popcorn not my wife something Jessie
echoed on her insta story you guys this
whole time I'm thinking that this that
I'm thinking this whole time that this
popcorn is something he just picked up
at the little newsstand and decided the
United Sydney had two flights and her
first flight
they both gave them popcorn if popcorn
was a hazard why are they giving it on
planes and while the public battles it
out online Sydney seems to have moved on
finding the humor in this whole thing
posting this pic of her little girl on
Monday holding a giant bag of yeah
popcorn alongside the caption she's so
cute
[Music]
foreign